les amis depuis le début cette élection
porte sur le changement et ce soir les
canadiens ont tourné la page sur dix
longues années et ils ont rejeté la
politique de la peur et de la division
et les canadiens ont demandé au npd de
continuer d'être porteurs de l'espoir et
de l'optimisme qui caractérise notre
parti tonight match ce soir mes pensées
sont avec les jambes ce soir d'inr que
j'ai rencontré partout au pays les gens
qui comptent sur nous en tant que néo
démocrates les premières nations les
fins que j'ai rencontré quelqu'un qui
pouvait compter sur nous pour demander
une enquête est essentielle sur lies
femme autochtone manquantes portées
disparues et pour mener à l'élimination
de la violence contre les femmes
les anciens travailleurs de l'auto que
je rentrais sexe qui ont perdu leur
emploi rénumérateur et qui était
finalement dans les rues de dents dans
le doute pour l'avenir de leurs enfants
de lillehammer que je rencontre et à
brossard et cetera vous devez savoir que
je vais travailler pour vous chaque jour
dans ce nouveau parlement entre nos
partis respectifs au cours des soixante
dix huit derniers jours l'accent a été
mis sur ces différences pour permettre
aux canadiens de faire un choix et
aujourd'hui des canadiens ont fait ce
choix et nous l'acceptons en toute
humilité mon mac os il y à quelques
instants j'ai perdu avec monsieur
trudeau monsieur un peu monsieur du
cette madame me et en dépit de nos
différences
au niveau politique sur la façon dont la
politique devrait être menée je remercie
monsieur un peu pour ses services au pij
féliciter monsieur trudeau sur son
accomplissement terrible pour lui et son
parti dans cette campagne monsieur
trudeau riz des engagements ambitieux
envers les canadiens dit qu'ils les
canadiens auront des attentes
importantes du prochain parlement
en travaillant avec les autres
parlementaires pour bâtir l'avenir que
nous souhaitons tous pour nos enfants et
nos petits enfants
c'est ce à quoi les gens ça tente de
nous nous allons nous tenir debout pour
vos communautés
nous allons nous battre pour vos emplois
pour vos familles nous allons lutter
pour protéger l'environnement
will be and web nous allons être sans
concession pour notre charge des
meilleurs soins de santé pour les gens
du pays notre lutte contre les
changements climatiques et la protection
de nos terres de nouveau de notre ère
nous serons des pieds résolu dans nos
efforts pour bâtir des relations de
nation à nation avec les premières
nations les inuits et les métis
c'est sur ces priorités sur bien
d'autres que les néo démocrates eux
feront des progrès réels et durables
dans ce parlement avec cette élection
les habitants du pillon des actuellement
que nous travaillons pour eux nous
n'allons pas les laisser tomber
je veux remercier d'abord les électeurs
d'oultremont d'avoir renouvelé leur
confiance en moi aujourd'hui et je veux
remercier tous les candidats et les
candidates qui ont fait campagne avec
courage sous la bannière du npd
je ne pourrai plus fier du travail
accompli avec le nord je ne pouvais pas
être plus fier de la diversité de la
force de notre équipe du npd tels que
rebecca ne nous l'a appelé vous avez
travaillé très fort pour bâtir notre pas
10 au sahara sera porteur cette année
nous avons bien sûr présenté durant ces
élections le plus de femmes et deux
candidats autochtones n'ont pas de
seulement de l'histoire de notre parti
mais de l'histoire du pays c'est simple
et même exclu c'est quelque chose qui me
donne beaucoup de fierté je ma vie
depuis plus de 40 ans
un merci infini pour qu'on amour la
gentillesse et ton soutien constant
merci à nos fils matt et greg et leurs
conjoints jazzmen et catherine et à nos
petits enfants juliette et raphaël je ne
pourrai jamais vous remercier assez pour
votre appui et votre amour thune ou néo
démocrates ici ce soir et dans toutes
les communautés à travers le pays merci
pour votre travail des plus sérieux
votre engagement envers notre cause
votre espérance votre optimisme mes amis
les néo démocrates ont fait des
contributions historiques pour rebâtir
ce pays que ce soit là l'assurance santé
que ce soit la sécurité des plis les
retraites est dorénavant le ministre
toujours pour les québécois un choix
réel
il
et après
m
et
en tant que parti avec des racines
partout dans ce pays edhi racines
profondes ici au québec que le prochain
chapitre commence dans nos efforts pour
bâtir un canada meilleur merci